i think i think
it's one of those things where it came
out at the time and it was a game
changer at the time yeah but i don't
think now it holds up as the
light is still a game i've i've
rewatched it several times trying to
find
what's about it was so amazing and every
time everyone
i'm like man the animation still holds
up the animation still holds up
it's just like it just it's just i don't
know it's just
nothing nothing much about it this is my
last episode of trash today i'm
leaving after this i can't handle it
okay okay akira
all right akira to me is like i think to
this day it still stands
as one of the most unique cinematic
experiences in anime
and i'm not just talking about that
you're wrong
in terms of like the flashy colors and
the fantastic animation
looks pretty like i'm not just talking
about it like that right but like i just
i don't know
like i've rewatched akira so many
[ __ ] times and
every time i've rewatched it especially
like you you have to see it in a big
screen as well
in my opinion like i went to go see it
okay because i went to go watch it
obviously i wasn't born when it came out
in cinemas
yeah but uh like a couple of years ago
they
did a re-screening of it in sydney in
australia um and for i think it was like
the 30th anniversary of the movie or
something on the big screen yeah and
like i loved it on the tv like watching
it in my room and [ __ ] was like [ __ ]
yeah
but watching it in the cinemas was like
holy [ __ ] like this is like an adventure
like this is this is just like such an
out of body experience with just
the music is god like the [ __ ] voice
acting is incredible like
everything about that has every every
single element of that movie
has a quality that can still stand to
like
modern anime cinema i agree with that
and like and i think that's why it's
just so incredible because you
watch it and you forget oh [ __ ] this was
made 30 [ __ ] years ago yeah but
that's my point i completely agree that
it's an experience that can stand out
in modern anime cinema right it's but
i'm i'm saying it's it's definitely not
as mind-blowing as it was back then
and i don't know man i think it's still
mind-blowing every time i rewatch it i
look like i'm in the middle of this
i feel like i can i can agree with both
i'm not saying it's the best
no no no no of course of course but
jesus christ that's good like i could
easily
have you have you read the manga there i
have not and i think that's part of why
i didn't enjoy it because it just felt
like
it felt like it kind of just ended it
was it didn't feel
like a complete experience well yeah
does the manga continue after the manga
is twice as long
so the movie actually the movie the
ending of the movie is completely
original
oh uh because uh otama released the
movie halfway
into a curious serialization because the
first like three volumes were so popular
that they were like we gotta make a
movie of this
and they made it but they were like i
haven't finished the manga yet what am i
gonna do bro bro i'm trying to finish it
so so the movie's completely original
and like the manga continues for another
like four volumes after the point of the
movie
okay and it's insane it's [ __ ] insane
like i highly recommend it and i'm not
just saying it's like a super fan of
akira i just think in terms of like
storytelling and just like you know i'm
just throwing [ __ ] keychains yeah
characters storytelling development like
honestly though
it's it's good [ __ ] well how many more
buzzwords can i throw in yeah right
progression synergy
again like i don't think it's the
greatest piece of like anime cinema
out there but like i i easily it's one
of those movies where i'm like
don't be fooled by the fact that it's 30
years old like i still think i can
easily recommend it to new watches
yeah you can definitely still watch it
today and not feel like it's dated
especially as like and as like a for me
like a visual experience and everything
like i just feel like
you know it's i don't know it's maybe
it's cause like cyberpunk has just kind
of died
recently i mean for like longest time
until
uh what what recent cyberpunk anime have
we got recently
like dora hedorah dora hedorah yeah
it's i mean i mean seeing seeing a world
like that is
a lot less you know seeing a world like
that now is a lot less common than it
was back then
yeah yeah but cyberpunk was kind of in
its prime oh yeah 80s was like [ __ ]
yeah
so like you can still watch akira and
feel like hey this is something i can't
really get today just because cyberpunk
is
just it's really rare to find out
because to me like akira is like one of
those movie
like those anime movies where every
single person i've asked
who is clearly not an anime fan and i
ask them what anime have you watched or
enjoyed
99 of them will say oh i watched akira
and i thought it was [ __ ] amazing
yeah it's just a good movie it's just a
really good movie it it almost defies
anime
in a sense which is really weird because
it's lovely because
which is really weird which is really
weird how what do you mean defies anime
what does that mean what does that mean
like it it goes be like
it has an enjoyment factor in it i i
can't exactly like describe i'm sure
someone can explain better than me but
there's
there's something about akira the
experience of watching akira that
you don't necessarily even have to
really like animations
which is really weird because when you
actually watch akira it is anime as [ __ ]
like everything about that is so anime
yeah and yet it somehow is almost
not anime at the same time